-♪ Face it ♪
-♪ Face it challenge ♪
-Here's how it works.
Each round we'll draw a card,
and it will tell us what face
that we both have to make.
Okay? And then we're going
to look in our mirrors,
make our faces, and then reveal
them on the count of three.
We'll stare at each other
for 10 seconds
while trying to hold our faces.
The first person to crack
a smile --
[ Laughter ]
-Pfft. Dude...
-This is gonna --
-This is gonna last 5 seconds.
-Crack a smile, laugh,
or break the face loses.
-Do they not know who we are?
-Let's see -- Let's see what
our first face is.
-Uh-huh.
-Screaming on a roller coaster.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, wait.
I think I've got mine.
Ready?
[ Laughter ]
Ready? Oh, man.
All right, ready?
[ Laughter ]
One --
One, two, three, go.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ] No.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause,
sad notes play ]
-I lost that one.
-No, that was me. That was me.
-All right,
let's do another one.
Bill, what is our next face?
-Oh, sexy vampire.
[ Laughter, cheering ]
-Sexy vampire.
[ Laughter ]
-[Stifled laugh]
-Okay.
One, two, three, go.
[ Laughter ]
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, we did it!
-Good job. Good job.
Neither one of us broke!
-Whoo!
-All right,
let's do another one.
-Pick one for us. All right.
You want to go?
-Here we go.
Stepped on a Lego barefoot.
-Okay.
[ Audience ohs ]
All right, all right.
-Stepped on a Lego barefoot.
-I've done this, this morning.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. Three, two, one.
-[ Coughs ]
-[ Laughs ]
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause,
sad notes play ]
-I laughed.
-I couldn't even look at you.
-I can't -- I put my eyes
down on you, and then --
-Oh, gosh. All right.
-Okay, last one.
-Last one here.
-Oh, brother.
Trying to dead lift
1,000 pounds.
-Trying to dead lift
-This morning.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Exactly.
Trying to dead lift
1,000 pounds.
All right, here we go.
[ Laughter ]
-It also looks like
something else.
[ Laughter ]
-All right, three, two, one.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause,
sad notes play ]
-Bill Hader, everybody!